Je marchais sur les traces de ma mère
avant même que je sois né
et je ne sais toujours pas comment arrêter.
En vieillissant, cela devient plus difficile.
Sérieusement, c'est plus difficile.
(Rires)
Ma mère m'a quand même appris beaucoup de choses,
mais surtout que l'amour surpasse tout.
Elle m'a appris que l'amour
est une action,
pas un sentiment.
L'amour est une façon d'être, une façon de faire,
c'est une façon d'écouter et une façon de voir.
DW : Aussi, l'idée à propos de l'amour,
les photographes,
ils cherchent l'amour lorsqu'ils prennent des photos.
Ils cherchent encore et encore et ils trouvent l'amour.
Durant mon enfance à Philadelphie,
j'étais entourée de personnes, dans ma famille et mon cercle d'amis,
qui prenaient des photos et utilisaient l'appareil familial
afin de raconter une histoire à propos de la vie,
d'une vie de joie,
à propos de ce que devenir une famille à Philadelphie signifiait.
J'ai passé la majeure partie de ma vie à chercher des images
qui s'interrogent sur les idées d'amour et de joie dans notre communauté
et de la vie de famille.
Il est très important de réfléchir
à l'action de l'amour qui surpasse tout en tant que verbe.
HWT : Parfois, je me demande si l'amour de l'observation est génétique
parce que, comme ma mère,
j'aime la photo depuis toujours.
Je crois parfois — après ma mère et sa mère —
que la photographie et les photos sont mon premier amour.
Sans vouloir offenser mon père,
mais voilà ce qui arrive à ceux qui m'appellent « jambon »
où qu'ils aillent.
Chaque fois que j'allais rendre visite à ma grand-mère,
elle cachait tous les albums photo
parce qu'elle avait peur que je demande :
« C'est qui sur cette photo ? »,
« Qui sont-ils pour toi et pour moi ?
Quel âge tu avais sur cette photo ? Quel âge j'avais sur cette photo ?
Pourquoi elles sont en noir et blanc ?
Est-ce que le monde était en noir et blanc avant que je naisse ? »
DW : Ça, c'est intéressant,
de penser au monde en noir et blanc.
J'ai grandi dans un salon de beauté à Philadelphie,
le salon de ma mère, à lire Ebony Magazine.
Les histoires que ces images racontaient
ne se trouvaient pas vraiment dans les journaux,
seulement dans l'album de famille.
Je voulais que l'album de famille soit dynamique pour moi,
une façon de raconter des histoires.
Un jour, j'ai découvert un livre à la bibliothèque municipale,
« The Sweet Flypaper of Life », par Roy DeCavara et Langston Hughes.
J'avais été attirée, à 7 ans,
par le titre, Flypaper (Papier tue-mouche) et Sweet (Doux),
mais quand on y pense, à 7 ans,
je regardais les superbes images que Roy DeCavara avaient créées
et j'ai réfléchi à des façons de raconter une histoire à propos de la vie.
Regarder est pour moi l'acte qui a essentiellement changé ma vie.
HWT : Mon ami Chris Johnson m'a dit que chaque photographe,
chaque artiste, essaie avant tout de répondre à une question.
Il me semble que ta question a été :
« Pourquoi le monde ne voit-il pas à quel point nous sommes beaux
et que puis-je faire pour l'aider à voir notre communauté comme je la vois ? »
DW : Lorsque j'étais en école d'art —
c'est sûrement la vérité —
un professeur m'a dit que je prenais la place d'un honnête homme.
Il a essayé de me décourager de poursuivre mon rêve de devenir photographe.
Il a tenté de m'humilier devant une classe remplie de photographes hommes.
Il m'a dit que je n'étais pas à ma place en tant que femme
et que tout ce dont j'étais capable était d'avoir un enfant
lorsqu'un honnête homme aurait pu avoir ma place dans cette classe.
Cette expérience m'a emmurée dans le silence.
J'avais mon appareil photo et j'étais déterminée à lui prouver
que je méritais ma place dans cette classe.
Plus tard, je me suis demandé pourquoi j'avais eu besoin de le lui prouver.
Je savais que c'était à moi que je devais prouver
que je pouvais faire bouger les choses.
J'aime la photo et personne ne peut m'empêcher de créer des images.
HWT : C'est là que je suis entré en scène.
DW : L'année de mon diplôme, je suis tombée enceinte.
Ouais, il avait raison.
Et je t'ai eu.
Je me suis débarrassée de ce langage sexiste qu'il avait utilisé contre moi,
j'ai pris mon appareil et j'ai fait des photos tous les jours.
J'ai pris des photos de ma grossesse en me préparant pour l'université.
Mais je pensais aussi à l'absence des photographes noirs
dans les livres d'histoire de la photographie
et je cherchais comment raconter une histoire.
Je suis tombée sur le livre de Gordon Parks,
« A Choice of Weapons »,
son autobiographie.
J'ai commencé à prendre des photos et à créer des images
et j'ai mis de côté la planche de contact des photos de ma grossesse.
Tu m'as ensuite inspirée à créer une nouvelle œuvre,
une œuvre qui dit : « Une femme prenant la place d'un honnête homme »,
« Tu as pris la place d'un honnête homme ».
J'ai utilisé ce langage, je l'ai inversé et j'ai dit :
« J'ai créé un espace pour un honnête homme, toi. »
(Applaudissements)
HWT: Merci maman.
Telle mère, tel fils.
J'ai grandi dans une maison remplie de photographies.
Elles étaient partout et ma mère transformait la cuisine en chambre noire.
Il n'y avait d'ailleurs pas que ses photos et les photos de famille.
Il y avait aussi des photos sur le mur avec et par des personnes inconnues,
des hommes et des femmes inconnus.
Merci maman.
(Rires)
Je fonctionne à mon rythme.
Vous l'avez vue faire ça ?
(Rires)
Les ficelles d'une marionnette.
J'ai grandi dans une maison remplie de photographies.
(Applaudissements)
Ces photos n'étaient pas que celles de personnes de notre entourage,
mais des photos de personnes que je ne connaissais pas.
Il était évident, d'après ce que j'avais appris à l'école,
que le reste du monde ne les connaissait pas non plus.
J'ai mis du temps à comprendre ce qu'elle cherchait à faire,
mais j'ai fini par comprendre.
J'avais 9 ans lorsqu'elle a publié ce livre,
« Black Photographers, 1840-1940 : A Bio-Bibliography ».
C'est stupéfiant pour moi d'envisager
qu'en 1840, les Afro-Américains prenaient des photos.
Qu'est-ce que cela signifie de penser
que vingt ou trente ans avant l'abolition de l'esclavage,
des gens apprenaient à lire,
et apprenaient à compter.
Ils devaient être à la pointe de la science et de la technologie,
apprendre les maths, la physique et la chimie
pour faire une seule photo.
Qu'est-ce qui les a poussés à faire tout ça sinon l'amour ?
Ce livre a amené un autre livre : « Black Photographers, 1940-1988 ».
Et ce livre en a amené un autre, et un autre, et puis un autre,
et un autre, et un autre,
et un autre, et un autre, et un autre, et un autre,
et un autre, et un autre, et encore un autre.
(Applaudissements)
Toute ma vie,
elle a édité et publié des dizaines de livres.
Elle a organisé de nombreuses expositions sur tous les continents,
pas toutes à propos de photographes noirs mais toutes inspirées par la curiosité
d'une petite fille noire de Philadelphie.
DW : J'ai découvert que ces photographes avaient des histoires à raconter
et que nous devions écouter.
Puis j'ai découvert
des photographes noirs tels qu'Augustus Washington,
qui a réalisé ces superbes daguerréotypes
de la famille McGill au début des années 1840 et 1850.
Leurs histoires avaient tendance à être différentes
et ils racontaient différemment la vie des Noirs pendant l'esclavage.
Ils parlaient aussi de la vie de famille, de la beauté et de leur communauté.
Je ne savais pas comment relier ces histoires
mais je savais que les professeurs devaient connaître cette histoire.
HWT : Je crois bien que j'ai été le premier élève de ma mère.
Contre mon gré et à mon insu — les ficelles d'une marionnette —
j'ai décidé de prendre un appareil photo
pour prendre mes propres photos
à propos de l'avant et du maintenant et vice-versa.
J'ai pensé à utiliser la photographie
pour montrer comment ce qui se passe en dehors du champ de l'appareil
peut influencer ce que l'on voit à l'intérieur.
La vérité est toujours entre les mains de celui qui prend l'image
et c'est à nous de réfléchir à ce qui a été omis.
J'ai pensé à utiliser ses recherches comme point de départ
à ce que je voyais dans la société
et je voulais réfléchir à l'utilisation d'images historiques
pour parler du passé encore présent
et aux différentes façons de parler
de la lutte constante pour les droits de l'homme et l'égalité des droits
à travers l'appropriation de photos
sous forme de sculpture, de vidéo,
d'installation et de peintures.
Une œuvre en particulier m'a touché le plus.
Elle continue de me nourrir.
Elle prend pour base cette photo d'Ernest Withers.
Il a pris cette photo en 1968
lors de la manifestation des éboueurs à Memphis,
des hommes et des femmes affirmant leur humanité les uns à côté des autres.
Ils tenaient des pancartes disant « Je suis un homme ».
C'était surprenant parce que la phrase avec laquelle j'ai grandi
n'était pas « Je suis un homme » mais « Je suis l'homme ».
J'ai été étonné de voir
que d'une déclaration collective pendant la ségrégation,
nous sommes passés à une déclaration en apparence égoïste après l'intégration.
Je voulais m'interroger là-dessus
et j'ai donc décidé de moduler ce texte autant que possible.
J'aime penser à la ligne du haut
comme une chronologie de l'histoire des États-Unis
et à la ligne du bas comme un poème.
Voici ce qu'elle dit :
Je suis l'homme. Qui est l'homme. Toi l'homme. Quel homme.
Je suis homme. Je suis hommes. Je suis, suis-je.
Je suis, je suis. Je suis, Amen.
DW : Ouah, c'est si fascinant.
(Applaudissements)
Ce que nous retenons de cette expérience,
ce sont les deux mots les plus puissants de la langue anglaise : « Je suis. »
Et nous sommes tous capables d'aimer.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)